moving on the federal government
reportedly is investigating the
e-cigarette giant Jule Labs as the
company faces increasing scrutiny over
the rise in youth vaping reports say the
FTC and Attorneys General in five states
and Washington DC are looking into
whether Jul used deceptive marketing
targeting minors in an exclusive
interview this week Jul CEO Kevin burns
told us his company his company never
intentionally targeted teenagers you say
your attention was never to market to
kids never to attract kids as users but
when you look back at your marketing
bright colors cool looking people fun
flavors wasn't it pretty obvious it was
a lifestyle advertisement that was
focused around millenials I would not
say it was oriented around youth
Gleneagles are pretty young but they're
not youth through a legal age in terms
of many of those now the company has
reiterated it never marketed to youth
coming up to you that he wants to make
it harder for kids he also pointed that
out changing the policy and he said that
the marketing department behind that
early ad no longer at the company